[Musique]
c'est l'image soigneusement entretenue l'
organisation colossale la ferveur
implacable le secret complet comme maman
ouais désinfectant sur G C lapavitsas
bahar Peter remplir la boîte Akashi
Laconia montre le cas du sabre si mama
ajusshi mabini's shit school kid shit
ouverture sentir un plasma Anatole a appelé un
canoë dans  journée mafiosi à expédier au sein de l'
organisation des Témoins de Jéhovah car
ailleurs la pédophilie est un péché un péché
qui est principalement traité en interne avec des
lois comme tout ce temps à la dynamique
au délicieux à un magasin à dîner
Varla Varla Sansui sur les enfants dans le Nagisa
demander un temps  missile
[Musique]
il y a 8 millions de Témoins de Jéhovah
dans le monde 115 000 le jour du Canada
frappent poliment à votre porte ne croyez-vous pas
qu'il faut célébrer les fêtes et ils
refusent les transfusions sanguines pour eux la
fin du monde est proche restons calmes
et  s'appuyer sur Jéhovah
à un moment donné, nous pouvons nous attendre à l'
attaque finale contre les gars et Satan est
partout Caleb qui aime la magie Jéhovah
ou Sat  un Satan voulez-vous vraiment
jouer avec quelque chose que Jéhovah déteste
derrière non seulement ces vidéos mais aussi
chaque magazine laissé à votre porte est un
empire de l'édition la société de la tour de guet
à Brooklyn New York c'est là que les
Témoins de Jéhovah ont élaboré leurs
politiques sur la pédophilie
Vanja mezzo  mezz callamezzo jamais piano
la maison CTA Oscar Jamie Satan Paseo de
Gama tige Oh professeur le piano ne sont pas
des arts conjugaux à notre numéro pouvez-vous descendre
les traditions qui ne voient pas mon
père pour moi ou un exemple endormi
qu'est-ce qu'il faisait
ils sont gras malodorants  plasma Anatole a encore
appelé une touche de piano sauf que demain
n'est pas si mal Van Diemen jour mafiosi pour
secouer tu sortirais de ta
leçon de piano et ton père était là en train d'attendre
pas ce qui s'est passé lol n'a pas bougé
melanie avait 10 ans son cauchemar hebdomadaire a
duré  cinq ans dans son adolescence,
elle quitte le piano et commence à sortir avec un
garçon très mal vu par les
témoins de Jéhovah. Melanie aurait été
convoquée à un juge  comité officiel le
tribunal interne de l'église sa punition une
réprimande publique devant les fidèles
qui étaient à l'origine de la punition le
professeur thermal le piano les asseoir sur
observer donc c'est ton agresseur qui
te jugeait pour ton comportement avec les garçons
pourquoi exactement suis sympathique tu as  on
peut avoir un mi go spear ça existe tu
accuses qui sont jaloux je te monte nous en
tant que maman illusion absolument ce qui
t'a arrêté Lisa se dirige en emoti Minaj baisse le
voile un hijab Allah fait un signal c'est
parce que son professeur est un pilier dans leur
communauté  un aîné c'est la première étape
dans la hiérarchie du pouvoir des
Témoins de Jéhovah au sommet de l'
échelle est l'organe directeur de New York
qui établit toutes les règles qui dictent la
façon dont les Témoins de Jéhovah vivent séparés
mangent la servitude la plus infinie pour
le temps énergétique donc  particulièrement violent
Zipit huit gauche tenir je reprends mes chansons c'est
une longue liste de péchés qui peuvent mener à l'
excommunication encore Benoit Poirot il le
sait par coeur
c'est un co  nvert qui a gravi les échelons et
est devenu ancien Jésus un foyer d'accueil est
mort s'est ouvert
Je n'ai jamais ou donné un journal télévisé avec lui ou
n'a-t-il pas dit bien fais cet exemple
c'est c'est un exemple donne l'exemple et
discipline les fidèles parfois même
pour l'abus sexuel d'un enfant une fois
Benoit Poirot il a dû interroger des
jeunes filles qui accusaient leur propre père
d'abus quel type de questions aviez-
vous à poser je suppose que je viens de Kadhafi ou
j'ai exagéré le temps je peux répéter PDG
Jeffrey Callas squ
Bennett ratio  échelle Alessio acceptable
au Québec un détective doit passer 160
heures en formation spécialisée avant de
pouvoir interroger une victime d'abus sexuel
pensez-vous qu'il est normal que quelqu'un
comme vous sans aucune formation pose
des questions aussi privées aux enfants la
discipline mignon était un linéaire rapide
quand c'est un  pour moi purifié
inapproprié dit études bibliques
quelqu'un nous devrions nous adresser au morne
mais c'était cette vie antérieure Benoit
Poirot il n'est plus un maintenant
il n'est même plus un  Le témoin de Jéhovah et le
courrier ont rapporté qu'Emily se rendait chez le nouveau
visiteur de Murray à Mount Authority
Benoit est un moulin et son père, c'était
lui qui attendait la fin de la leçon de sa fille
alors que son professeur de piano l'
aurait agressée dans la
pièce voisine. Sherman Poppy imagine un appel le
Rico suave et a choisi les réponses de parade
écartez-vous monsieur particulier oof j'ai vu dans
notre chat sauvage il y a 6 ou 5 ans Bowdoin
Parker manque d'équité ils disent pas d'équité aucun
homme sérieux particulier studio
huile d'olive télépathique alors la classe a mis en place une
nappe
Milani garde son secret pendant près  20
ans jusqu'à ce qu'elle rencontre une deuxième
victime présumée une réunion qui convainc les deux
femmes de se manifester le professeur de piano
est convoqué devant des comités judiciaires
Melania arrive chez elle avec son père
et son mari seulement un trouble
Mohammed Rav via la démo G La maman de Mira Liu
Shui Jamaïque  L'étang de Pam Jamaica et les
mormons disent tous qu'il est possible de supprimer l'
offensive er6 encore gâcher l'
argent attendu.ils ont jeté Emma a
catastrophe parce que Mélanie est obligée de
tout dire devant son agresseur présumé
c'est une règle de base parmi les
témoins de jéhovah tirée d'une interprétation
du verset biblique
César vapo sauf T del conte même pas
disponible permet d'endommager le fermier du milieu
tant de choix que la lune Revere observe
trois ecclésiastiques beaucoup même imposent la
délicatesse homme modd un poète
chomp dire pave Hawks se passe si
passivité destination soudanaise Phu Quoc
encore plus rapide
permettez-moi le candidat au portefeuille de monsieur Thomas
est modulé par Mustafa Kemal Pacha qui
multitudes MA Jimenez reconnaissance
conçu dans une Fiat sont toujours considérés comme
moins  heureux monsieur  Rickey reporter le placard
sont nettement mieux réussir LaSalle
rapidement déplacer pourquoi pas pourquoi
préféré gagner attaché respectivement
République ils sont mutilés d'abord avec pour
compléter le mouvement compassion d'une
logique Tim Tschida Thomas après le
témoignage des deux victimes le
professeur de piano est expulsé de la  Témoins de
Jéhovah
il fait alors appel de la décision Mélanie
doit répéter l'opération deux fois de plus
avant que l'excommunication ne soit confirmée mais
ça ne dure pas longtemps
elle donk
nakatsu dinde Bob Suleiman passe
zone exposée Samba tu fais des blessures corporelles il a
un travail de mât en coton plus fissile trop longtemps
donc luxuriant peut devenir étape je vois Dallas une
boucle tu vois un premier voyage de liaison pour
père et fils ils sont rejoints par trois
amis tous les Témoins de Jéhovah la
mère du garçon n'oubliera jamais le jour où
ils sont revenus Jason Murphy
électricien cytokine en Laconie montre Ca  sa de
Bercy mamanu à shimon pénis le sommet
sur bananajana
elle est venue ici pour chier sur le pénis oui
Monsieur kill monsieur la musique ET
avec vous numéro deux we l'homme en
question est un ancien d'une autre
congrégation Benji Lazarus tropic am su
mo mafia prononcer ela congregatio  la
cañada se soucie des problèmes de catégoriquement
la police a fait une tentative de violatin
stupeur feu avez-vous fait confiance aux anciens à
ce moment-là supporter Sam pasa bien est
aidé il vous désosse quel mystère gee
si seulement sans jambes Anka vorlix indice
[Musique]
mais avant de prendre soin de la  agresseur les
anciens s'assuraient d'une chose qu'il
fallait tenir sucre fella Papa Holly
le ouais mr.  DiPalma montre les commandes
Kiku hein halète monsieur viens monsieur Papa Texans
Casca Regla feu dans un cas comme celui-ci
signaler une agression sexuelle n'est pas
obligatoire au Québec ni la police
ni les services de protection de l'enfance ne s'appellent
les Témoins de Jéhovah régleront encore une fois
l'affaire en interne avec
un autre comité judiciaire Monfils Davis
actuellement Devon j'utilise personnellement l'ère
sélection du comté feuillu votre
fils de cinq ans a dû expliquer ce qui
s'est passé devant son agresseur exact
Mahal l'endroit assez fou
cannabis sur sexuel agressif c'était une
incursion en mer même skc avisé  genres sur
pour moi Porter près du comité tell
Jadzia voir Jonas sur l'hôtel de voyage
nomade Suva triplet scelera thé est la
riche confusion devant trois juges
le petit garçon explique ce qu'il a enduré
mais son agresseur présumé le contredit
et essaie de tout expliquer
effets sur l'ecstasy oh ma fille sur le
Neelix pas d'assignation à comparaître échapper aux dépôts sur le
court métrage est vraiment simple l'
ouverture de l'Amérique  ss ellen terry ordonne en bref était
l'agresseur puni
abend oh non Papa no xpk poker sur
alma mater disponible bovis un
gee biblique piquer une personne swaha coupable
Saba huile sale
c'est l'une des règles fondamentales pour les
témoins de Jéhovah vous avez besoin de deux
témoins ou d'une confession pour confirmer un
allégation d'acte répréhensible
ZV sauf ISA possède deux équivalents
sauf un site la decisión de saucé un
site Iridessa jamal murray siège la
decisión de jure Alamos a rencontré un
lien commun Catherine
la bonne chrétienne est maintenant ébranlée jusqu'au
fond elle contacte finalement les
autorités mais afin de  épargner à son
fils plus de traumatismes elle renonce à la réalité la
rattrapera finalement devient
un cercle accro au cinéma des chevilles ouvrières comme
Frank le déployeur Chuvalo F baisé
heureux peut-être mais à 14 ans
marie-claude Lavoie porte un lourd
fardeau qu'elle avait été sexuellement  abusée par
un proche elle se confie à ses
amis et le regrette instantanément
cris acoustiques belliqueux diffusion
comme orgasme
medic  als cas sera traité
différemment son agresseur n'est pas un témoin g 'OVA
donc les anciens n'ont aucun pouvoir sur
lui
mais ils ont un pouvoir sur Matty près
à 14 ans, elle a convoqué pour s'expliquer
devant un comité judiciaire aussi il a commis une
faute PP la lumière  une heure de l'après-midi  ce n'est pas
ce qui s'est passé patchs de sécurité calamaro
essentiellement contact image sexuelle quelque chose
dit e peu beaucoup plus confortable
ne combattez pas l'athlète pour mater la
régression ne souza une copie numérique
particulièrement lente se marier le froid est tout seul
dans une petite pièce sans sa mère
c'est parce que  les Témoins de Jéhovah
interdisent aux femmes d'assister à des
comités judiciaires attendant d'entendre l'
histoire de Mary codes trois hommes dans la quarantaine alarmés c'est
pourquoi Melissa pardonnera Giovanna
Foods nouvelles Eastwood heureusement
bégayé éducateur d'attitude Hassan
Cassidy
elle a paralysé apparemment c'est tout elle
madame un titre desserts ma sucah Stasi
Mousasi  vêtu dire non non inverse de tout
charlatan Amérique
appelez-moi un rabat oui une fleur de bouillie jaune
bismuth le tableau de moi-même comme collage
été à l'homme j'aime ralentir son plaisir
ouais commun Mandy le plus malade similaire
David s'il vous plaît un marteau sur la bande à
la fin des trois anciens  priant avec elle
et l'absolvant de ses péchés, elle est enfin
sur le point de quitter la Salle du Royaume quand
Les républicains étaient de jeunes leaders Otis gentil
vautrer
Louella prima gap c'est dans le Lancaster
attends juste de gaspiller un skate un
missile
[Musique]
notre société à Mohammed penche avait l'
argent alors comme Thelma oh ouais
madame un titre ou Sulaco me va bien étoile
bien ouais d'accord  voir une question humiliante se
référer sans aucun doute aux témoins de jéhovah
il semble essentiel qu'une version de cette
même question puisse être trouvée dans le formulaire que
les anciens devaient remplir cela s'appelle
la maltraitance des enfants Tala mémo question neuf
combien d'anciens ont estimé que la victime était
quelque peu fautive  ou volontairement
participé aux actes nous atteignons le
laboratoire médical ouest aîné où cette
question
au comité judiciaire qu'il dit qu'il se
souvient de ce qui a été dit à l'époque il
ne dit pas qu'il est disponible pour aider
Mary à cloner si elle en a besoin manque veut des
concavités sur mon  vite mon juste je garde
notre conscience
deux mains comptent je suis un développeur Shire
vous permet de servir Ali Pacha six ans
après le voyage de pêche il y a un
doute persistant dans  l'esprit de la
mère du petit garçon et ce qu'elle voit à la
télévision le 28 mai 2002 ne fait rien
pour apaiser ce doute ce soir sur Dateline,
ils ont pris la force la plus puissante
de leur vie, leur propre église exposant
ce qu'ils disent est un terrible  mal
mahakasyapa leçon monsieur
sasame sook nous une escarmouche parsecs
Jericho Nick Miller a écrit un adulte
ouais le ne viens pas wah le lendemain
matin elle demande à son fils alors âgé de onze
ans s'il se souvient du
voyage de pêche il n'a rien oublié
sa mère  enregistre leur échange dans son
journal au Maroc et en Italie calme cesse
un tipo de Lessman Posse Labrador TV
victime
Asifa Tripathi parsis Aloha fait
occasionnellement bateau un Oh
voyageur localisé faire Tony
dans l'Oregon direction conducteur consciemment
d'italia paporova limousine pauvreté en
particulier Delmar éducation ect hey
sophistiqué  personne la théorie des asanas
viens ici fille une famille
procédure agressive mo conjugal le mal est fou
s'il vous plaît machinerie tatie sur nécessairement
manœuvrer pisc  azzi sur le
service d'émission polyvalent de près de Kade canoë
pouvons-nous patty
virgule l'homme qui aurait abusé de son
fils est décédé récemment sans jamais avoir
fait l'objet d'une enquête, elle a laissé un
témoin de jéhovah avec sa fille mais
son mari et son fils font toujours partie
de l'église c'est à  protéger son
garçon qu'elle voulait son identité dissimulée
Monfils un service tompa seule condition
économique sur siani ils ont fait nakamura d'
une pré-fête
oui se da corps-contact avec ma
le problème siroter Alicia idiot politiquement l'
équipe est passée par-dessus Donna FASFA folle sexuelle
ma voir à part  ma grave Estella
Mousavi pop la police Lisa par personne
Lucy
toi
[Musique]
c'est un empire construit sur du papier d'impression
aujourd'hui sous la menace d'un autre type de
papier les milliers de dossiers détaillant
les inconduites sexuelles au sein des Témoins de
Jéhovah ces gens leurs secrets
leurs secrets étaient terribles
la société de la tour de guet à Brooklyn
Barbara Anderson a passé dix ans ici
avec son mari dans les années 1980, elle est l'un
des f  nouvelles femmes à se rapprocher du
siège du pouvoir chez les Témoins de Jéhovah,
c'est une vie si merveilleuse pour moi et je suis
si heureuse de faire partie de la famille Bethel
une mère parfaite et une bénévole modèle
Barbara Anderson est rapidement devenue
la société de la tour de guet  chercheuse en chef
le 8 octobre 1991, lorsque le
magazine de l'église publie un article choquant sur la
pédophilie, elle est stupéfaite par les commentaires,
c'était une avalanche d'informations et
cela ne s'était jamais produit auparavant et nous n'avions jamais
imaginé qu'il y avait tant de centaines de
lettres de victimes inondées au
siège causant  un tumulte tant
d'agresseurs étaient des aînés, ce n'est pas seulement
ici aux États-Unis parce que
nous entendions des gens de l'autre côté des mers
et j'ai donc pensé et pensé que pouvons-nous
faire à ce sujet que pouvons-nous faire à ce sujet
pour obtenir le gouvernement  corps pour comprendre
qu'il s'agit d'un problème grave, le
conseil d'administration des Témoins de
Jéhovah, un groupe de sept hommes plus âgés,
pensait être le pipeline vers Dieu ici
sur terre le  leurs ordres sont clairs, le mot
est venu d'en haut par certains membres
de l'instance dirigeante pour arrêter tout
intérêt pour ce sujet nous sommes incapables d'
aider les victimes chaque mouvement qu'elle propose
est rejeté catégoriquement l'un après l'autre
même le plus simple de tous  vous signalez
laissez les autorités s'en occuper c'est si
simple et arrêtez d'enquêter
vous dites que depuis 25 ans cela a
changé du tout absolument pas
ils enquêtent toujours dessus enfin un
jour Barbara l'a eu elle commet un
délit impardonnable en prime time
car le  la société de la tour de guet ne
voulait pas reconnaître que ces filles
disaient la vérité
Barbara et son mari Joe sont expulsés
des Témoins de Jéhovah son crime
calomniant l'organisation dans les médias
son incapacité à contrôler sa femme
leur fils ne leur a pas parlé  à 14
ans, ils ne connaissent même pas leurs
petits-enfants, ce n'est pas une vengeance sur une
religion, cela n'a rien à voir avec
cela, c'est la protection d'une
génération future de personnes.  e sa meilleure arme
documente qu'elle a pu
dénicher des mémos, des instructions secrètes et
le tristement célèbre formulaire de mémo tella sur la maltraitance des enfants
qu'elle a trouvé dans des dossiers judiciaires en
Californie, ils n'avaient aucune idée qu'ils
avaient un formulaire composé et cela me dit
que vous devez avoir  un grand nombre de cas
si vous avez un formulaire préparé pour cela
[Musique] des
documents relatant l'inconduite
des fidèles peuvent être trouvés dans chaque
Salle du Royaume ici aussi dans la petite ville
de McAllister dans l'Oklahoma ces fichiers
sont secrets et parfois impossibles à obtenir
même quatre policiers
armés d'un mandat eh bien le détective
il a décidé de signifier un mandat de perquisition dans
la salle du royaume parce que nous lui avons dit qu'il
y a des documents qu'ils conservent comme preuve de
ces événements je sais où se trouve le
classeur il m'a eu au téléphone il a
dit Debbie  ces classeurs se sont vides et
mon cœur est monté dans ma gorge
je me suis senti physiquement malade ils sont partis il n'y
avait rien à obtenir les documents sont
partis ceux sur lesquels Debbie McDaniel
comptait t  o prouver qu'elle dit la
vérité allons-nous maintenant à peu près un
pâté de maisons de la vieille maison de Ronnie où
il avait tous les enfants tout le temps
irani est Ronnie Lawrence l'ancien
chef des Témoins de Jéhovah à
McAlester ce qui s'est passé dans cette maison il a
abusé sexuellement pas  juste moi mais un certain nombre
d'enfants dans la piscine et la baignoire
et le cabanon près de la piscine les allégations
sont troublantes entre les âges de 7 et
13 Debbie dit qu'elle a été maltraitée par Ronnie
Lawrence
un aîné qui a insisté pour garder deux
enfants de sa congrégation le  le
pire était la pénétration avec des cuillères
qu'il gardait dans la salle de bain ses doigts
partout, c'était pour moi le pire,
me sentant comme si j'étais impuissant dans la
baignoire pendant qu'il faisait ça, comme avec tant
d'autres victimes, elle garde son secret
près et encore comme  tant d'autres, c'est
elle qui sera expulsée de
la communauté par son agresseur présumé pour
voix de bébé
dix ans plus tard, Debbie est de retour dans le
giron mariée et enceinte quand une femme
la contacte, elle est venue me voir et avait des
questions et elle a finalement arrêté de danser
autour du sujet et a juste dit que
tu t'agressais en courant - une autre
victime présumée qui avait signalé ses propres abus
aux anciens
sans succès quatre ans plus tôt, elle
devient le deuxième témoin que Debbie
a besoin de
Ronnie Lawrence sera enfin
excommunié grâce au témoignage
de deux femmes et d'un homme c'était
une vague de soulagement complet car pour une
raison quelconque j'ai pensé que c'était génial je n'aurai plus
jamais à le regarder je peux aller à la
salle du royaume  et sortir et servir et
ne jamais avoir à le voir, mais elle le
revoyait chaque semaine,
c'est parce qu'assister aux
réunions de la congrégation était l'une des conditions qu'il
devait respecter pour être accepté à nouveau dans
la communauté, il devait également s'excuser,
ce qu'il a fait dans ce  lettre Rania
Lawrence est ensuite autorisé à revenir dans la
congrégation sous certaines conditions,
il lui est interdit de répondre aux prières et d'
utiliser un microphone, mais curieusement, aucune des
conditions d8 ne l'interdit  Je suis passé
devant une
école primaire et je l'ai vu prendre une fille
qui était nouvelle dans la région, alors je suis allé la voir
et elle a été choquée qu'il ait
choisi ses enfants.  il avait emmené ses
enfants manger de la glace pendant des mois et les
anciens locaux n'avaient rien dit qu'elle n'avait aucune
idée qu'il cachait était un
agresseur d'enfants reconnu avéré avec cet appel d'avertissement à
la mère de la fille debbie a enfreint une
règle leur règle de silence  détaillé dans
cette note confidentielle de 1989, aucun des
abonnés n'est censé savoir pourquoi Rania
Lawrence a été excommuniée.
librement
mais les anciens savent que d'autres enfants
ont également passé du temps à la maison de Ronnies
devrions-nous les contacter les anciens ont
demandé au siège la tour de guet
répond
[Musique]
mais cela n'empêche pas les autres de c
oming forward alléguant des abus de la part de
Ronnie Lawrence, il a été expulsé une deuxième
fois puis réintégré cinq
ans plus tard
[Musique]
un dimanche après son retour du service,
nous l'abordons êtes-vous en contact avec
mes enfants monsieur
vous niez toujours
avoir sexuellement excité
le  d'autres encore avez-vous écrit des
lettres mais vous dites que vous n'avez pas
admis avoir abusé sexuellement d'enfants ne l'a jamais
touchée si mon père s'arrêtait il
appellerait le shérif parce que nous sommes des
visiteurs indésirables je ne veux plus jamais y retourner
encore une fois, c'est là qu'au mot est
la place de Fellowship deux fois excommuniée les
deux fois pour comportement immoral mais un
type d'immoralité différent, alors quelle était
la raison de votre deuxième
cornée d'éjection, mais cela signifiait vraiment parce que
vous étiez gay, vous pouvez être gay
dans l'organisation  vous ne pouvez tout simplement pas avoir de
relations sexuelles avec quelqu'un qu'elle est mariée et la
mère son homosexualité est un scandale
les témoins de Jéhovah qui ne signalent presque jamais
les pédophiles présumés n'hésitent pas  tate
de signaler debbie aux autorités,
ils ont pris l'habitude d'appeler la
protection de l'enfance et la police
lorsqu'ils essayaient de
prouver que j'avais perdu la tête ou que j'étais
mentalement instable, c'est du
harcèlement incessant et Debbie finit par l'
enregistrer  à la police, c'est à ce moment-là que les agents
ici nom de Ronnie Lawrence pour la
première fois la police obtient un mandat pour
fouiller la Salle du Royaume vous vous souvenez que le
classeur était vide mais quelques
jours se sont écoulés et ils ont reçu un appel téléphonique
d'un homme qui a dit servir  il a de nouveau
servi le mandat il est retourné il a
obtenu tout il a obtenu tout ce qu'il m'a appelé
et c'était la victoire ils l'ont obtenu
ils ont obtenu les documents
Debbie ne sait pas qui c'était mais l'un
des membres de la congrégation sauvegarderait
tous les fichiers  traitant de Ronnie
Lawrence et d'abus sexuels,
c'est un chef d'église de longue date à
McAllister assis derrière les barreaux accusé d'
avoir agressé sexuellement quatre personnes il y a plus
de 30 ans,
Ronnie Lawrence est accusé de
agresser sexuellement quatre enfants une victoire
avortée l'affaire ne dépasse jamais l'
enquête préliminaire Debbie a 20 ans
trop tard le délai de prescription dans l'
Oklahoma est expiré et il n'y a aucune
chance pour une affaire civile ou
pénale contre Ronnie Lawrence mais à quel
point Debbie McDaniel est-elle bonne  cas d'un
point de vue juridique en termes de force,
c'est vraiment très bien, nous avons des témoignages
sous serment et nous avons des documents montrant
la dissimulation du siège, je veux dire que
vous n'obtenez tout simplement pas ce genre de preuves
contre une église jamais
marquer Edwards est Debbie  avocat, il
représente également trois autres
victimes présumées de ronee Lawrence, tous de
Janelle, tous de cette seule église dans
cette petite ville, vous pouvez donc imaginer
combien de victimes il y a là-bas
lorsque vous commencez à additionner chaque
petite ville, je veux dire c'est c'est c'est
ahurissant il veut que justice soit rendue à son
client
il espère poursuivre les Témoins de Jéhovah
là où ils ont leur siège à New York
S  tate
[Musique]
pendant ce temps Debbie McDaniel vit avec
les conséquences de ses actes ses
parents ne lui parlent plus
sa mère lui manque terriblement fuir est un
cadeau qui continue de vous donner ne
vous réveillez jamais un jour en pensant que je peux appeler
mon  maman et tu sais qu'elle ne t'appelle
pas tu sais que ça ne va pas finir ça ne
t'en va pas
vingt-quatre ans après sa dernière
leçon de piano huit ans après que son agresseur présumé a
été expulsé au milieu de toute façon il
franchit enfin les portes d'un
poste de police qui maman  qui est apparemment
un ministre c'est un Jerry Palafox Ness bleu à
part ce qui la motive maintenant est sa
colère son ancien professeur de piano n'a pas été
exécuté longtemps
il a rejoint les Témoins de Jéhovah
sans remplir deux conditions clés
avouer et demander pardon à ses
deux victimes présumées jim evridge  un
ministre et il a été réintégré attendez
Sanibel supposez qu'une personne en particulier vous a mis un
bip quand ça m'a
complété la catastrophe pourquoi k kharon un agresseur un pédophile  e
j'ai essayé de choisir avec ces méthodes avec
un homme qui a conduit c'est violet et bébé c'est
essentiellement une collaboration était en
accepteur dans acceptable
[Musique]
il frappe aux portes le samedi
matin car nous avons découvert qu'il nie toujours
avoir agressé Mélanie Poitier et il a
refusé  pour répondre à nos questions parce que
signaler des abus sexuels au sein de la
communauté des Témoins de Jéhovah est si rare,
tout comme les condamnations pénales,
nous avons trouvé deux cas au Québec dans l'un de
ces cas
masamune un aîné de Châteauguay Ouest
reconnu coupable d'avoir agressé sexuellement une
fille de 11 ans Simon j'ai perdu  sa place
en tant qu'ancien mais il n'a jamais été expulsé
des Témoins de Jéhovah, même avec
son casier judiciaire dans le monde entier,
l'étau se resserre pour les
témoins de Jéhovah L'Australie est un exemple de
ce qui pourrait être le pire abus sexuel culturel
et dissimulation dans un  église que
nous avons jamais vu cette église est les
Témoins de Jéhovah une commission royale
trouve 1 000 dans six cas potentiels d'
abus sexuels d  détaillé dans les dossiers détenus par
les Témoins de Jéhovah combien ont été
signalés à la police pas un seul n'a été
signalé par l'église les autorités laïques que
vous avez entendues pas un seul
cas signalé sur 1006 qui a laissé les
Témoins de Jéhovah lutter pour défendre
leurs actions ce que vous pouvez faire est  vous pouvez
signaler aux autorités de protection de l'enfance
c'est fait dans certains cas la
Commission royale a récemment publié son
rapport la conclusion que les Témoins de
Jéhovah ne protègent pas leurs
propres enfants et les enfants des autres
car le risque que ces
pédophiles impunis qui restent dans la
communauté  récidive
mais c'est en Californie que les
Témoins de Jéhovah ont payé le
prix le plus élevé ce qui s'est passé ici est
où la première fois au monde un jury a
constaté que la tour de guet avait consciemment
ignoré les droits et la sécurité des
enfants les instructions étaient de garder
ces pédophiles secrets Rick Simmons et
son  La cliente Candice Conti a été la première
à gagner l'affaire d'abus sexuels  contre les
Témoins de Jéhovah à l'âge de neuf ans
Candice a été agressée par cet homme
qui faisait du porte-à-porte avec elle
c'était un pédophile et les anciens le savaient
ce document interne est la preuve que la
communauté était tenue dans l'ignorance quelle était
la  raison pour laquelle la congrégation n'a pas été
notifiée nous ne rendons pas cela public à
la congrégation c'est confidentiel un
peu trop confidentiel pour le jury
qui a statué que le pédophile aurait dû
être surveillé et les membres ont averti
le prix que les témoins de Jéhovah ont été
condamnés à payer vingt huit millions
dollars de dommages-intérêts qui sont venus avec une
reconnaissance implicite qui faisait partie d'
une politique mondiale plus large dans chaque
congrégation dans le monde aux États-
Unis et en Amérique du Nord partout pour
garder secrets les agresseurs sexuels d'enfants connus que
les Témoins de Jéhovah sont prêts à
payer cher pour garder ce secret  quatre
mille dollars par jour, c'est défini un
juge a giflé la société de la tour de guet
quatre mille dollars pour chaque jour  l'
église refuse de remettre au tribunal
leur liste de pédophiles
ils ont compilé cette liste pendant au
moins vingt ans
quatre mille dollars par jour n'est rien
pour les Témoins de Jéhovah La Watchtower
vaut des milliards de dollars en immobilier
et Holdings cette liste de pédophiles  est
au cœur de deux procès en
Californie et cela pourrait conduire à des dizaines
d'autres cas car pour Candace Conte et
ses 28 millions de dollars de dommages et intérêts,
il a été réduit à seulement trois
millions une cour d'appel a statué que les
témoins de Jéhovah n'étaient pas obligés
d'avertir  leurs membres au sujet d'un
agresseur d'enfants avoué dans leur communauté est-il
raisonnable et faisable de demander au
témoin ovas d'avertir chaque congrégation du
pédophile les témoins de Jéhovah
contrairement à la plupart des religions ne se mélangent pas avec d'
autres groupes toute votre vie est
témoin de Jéhovah et il est donc
raisonnable  pour eux d'avertir les parents
de la congrégation afin qu'ils puissent
protéger leurs enfants et ne pas permettre à
ces mêmes c  levier et
agresseurs sexuels d'enfants en série sophistiqués pour avoir
accès à une victime
au Canada il n'y a eu qu'une seule
poursuite similaire contre les témoins de Jéhovah
un tribunal a accordé à l'ancienne membre vicki
5 000 $ pour dommages psychologiques les
témoins de Jéhovah pourraient ressentir la
chaleur qu'ils commencent à changer  les
consignes qu'ils donnent aux
parents seront désormais parfois prévenus d'
un prédateur sexuel dans la communauté s'il est
considéré comme dangereux et depuis le
1er août une victime n'a plus à affronter
son agresseur face à face stone
devrait devenir nevah québécois sunnite
la mosquée est terminée les cils représentent le bas
Ted Koppel Osceola salud mash
[Musique]
nous avons contacté les témoins de jovis
Le siège social canadien à l'extérieur de Toronto,
ils ont refusé de répondre à nos questions à la
place, ils nous ont dirigés vers leur
site Web avec les politiques qu'ils ont
en place où un enfant peut '  Je ne viens pas
vous dire que j'ai été agressé par ces
politiques, ils sont devenus un
endroit dangereux  général voir Lafayette
classe boho rapido circuit de filtre GG a
séparé ce thermique de peut séparer notre
parodie de l'installation de pédophilie afin que la
Terre soit juste au-dessus du so perd
observateur cure salade organisation salons
axiome bascule Akiba le magazine de l'
organisation supercellulaire occupée co-dirigée
couper public dire réseau jalawla  est un
niveau de dire que le droit de la personne
est un désir du criminel
[Musique]
vous